special projects Nicole we have a
situation what are you doing I'm
analyzing glenn greenwald's verizon
metadata this takes priority follow my
instructions precisely ready I are you
ready ready ready yeah turn on your
computer
it's already on oh you're good kid now
listen to me very carefully I need you
to hack a website yes I've been waiting
for this moment thank you so much
tonight we dine in Hell your youthful
exuberance is wasting precious time now
I'll give you the information call me
back when you have the data uh I can't
handle the suspense I gotta get down
there all right miss winters where are
we oh um have you hacked the site I yes
I hacked the site what's your cover
blown no is the data I mentioned still
there yes the data is all here finally
now MS winters I know an agent has to do
whatever he or in your case she has to
to get the job done so if you had to
sleep with someone to get this
information that's none of my business I
didn't sleep with anyone to sleep with
in order to get this in it's been like a
minute read me the data dear Henry Topol
1943 thanks for opening an account with
Geo city's comm the world's leading
email provider now and forever yes yes
your password is password one two three
password one two three I've been trying
to remember that for years did you crack
Soviet ciphers how can you not remember
password one two three well now it's
tricky when it's a combination of
letters and numbers did I have any
emails in my inbox yes a few thousand
reading to me most of them seemed to be
spam Amazon says you're Bing Crosby
cassette has ship oh oh but one is super
high priority from a mr. Logan Wow
from 1998 Wow Logan he was my partner on
thing what does he say Henry I'm sending
this to your personal email so you'll
see it tonight just wanted to let you
know the agency has signed off on our
little experiment the test subject has
been acquired he's a blank slate
susceptible to hypnotic suggestion when
the project is over his memory will be
wiped and he'll spend the
his life making paintings of his own
feet in the bathtub whoa is this keep
reading let's see
PS let me know asap whether we should
use this test subject for good or evil
if I don't hear from you in the next day
I'll assume it's for evil huh poor old
Logan what happened to him he was torn
apart and then eaten by the test subject
oh my god well omelets and eggs MS
winters omelets and eggs